all right here's the official story from
the Daily Mail biggest fail in campaign
launches in history Ron DeSantis is
mocked for shambolic Twitter room
presidential announcement with Elon Musk
that crashes five times and leaves users
bamboozled
yeah it was around six o'clock or a few
minutes before six I get the
notification because Elon is about to
start this Twitter space we're really
excited to hear this
I was really excited to hear it and it
started late and then wasn't working and
a lot of people uh man I gotta tell you
I like Elon Musk it does great work I
like Rhonda Sanders he does great work
but I am not gonna pull punches on this
one
the obvious mistakes they were making
they did not properly plan for this I
have no idea how it came off so bad for
one I understand if there's more people
than you expect but this is a
presidential announcement getting
hundreds of thousands of people was
obvious when we had we had Stephen
Crowder on this show we had about 200
000 viewers okay now if you're gonna
have Ron DeSantis and Elon Musk you got
to prepare for that I presume they did
to the best of their abilities but
Twitter wasn't able to handle it but
here's the thing a lot of people were
saying oh you know the servers were
overloading I was I I understand that
happens no no no no look some of the
problem was like the main host guy was
like he muted himself randomly and I
don't think he noticed he was talking in
the mid-centers just mute and then Elon
unmuted himself while I think I was
talking so you got an echo because they
were sitting next to each other I'm like
dude those are production mistakes not
technical errors and if this was done on
YouTube it probably would have had
substantially more live viewers
I think I think decision was going for a
a big bang gimmick we'll do this on
Twitter spaces with Elon it's huge for
us but they weren't ready for it and it
really pulled a lot of wind out of their
sales now there's a lot of things we can
talk about in terms of Rhonda said
Rhonda Sanders as a candidate but uh you
know what do you guys think
yeah no I agree with you these are
technical problems that should have been
sorted out long ahead of time uh it's
kind of perplexing whenever you see a
massive campaign that's well funded and
has a you know a lot of backing behind
it
fail at something so basic I mean it
happens the best of us everybody makes
mistakes but it's just such a lost
opportunity I heard that uh it was
because someone because they were using
musk's account because he has so many
followers that caused an issue I don't
know how true that is it's just
something I read
um so I don't know but I I mean it was
just matter right it shouldn't matter I
mean again if they just did it on
YouTube they'd had a million plus
viewers and it would run fine yeah
totally I mean or Rumble this was almost
clobuchar blizzard like level right like
that like let's let's be real Klobuchar
blizzard level it was near near that but
yeah they should have been prepared
there's no question about it now they're
getting roasted it was it is funny
though that uh at first the media was
like oh it's stupid it's gonna fizzle
then it got so much attention that it
crashed it's a lot of people man don't
get me wrong it I think that it it was a
good it would have been a a good thing
had it gone properly
um I think that the fact that it was
that DeSantis has totally been ignoring
the Legacy Media
um I think that's a good thing right
um I also think that it's good because
it kind of puts the Legacy media on
notice obviously when you've got you
know
organizations like Vanity Fair running
that that headline they did where they
say that they they should have been Dave
brought David Duke or whatever I was
dying you know it's ridiculous of course
um and the the overall tone from The
Establishment media the the Legacy Media
is you know ridiculous so so for
conservatives to go to them and even
even present an opportunity for them to
cover is is almost silly because you
know they're going to say oh well you're
just a racist Nazi huh and so there's no
reason to talk to him when the Twitter
space got to around 460 000 people it
was crashing it was it was crashing well
before that but I got in right when it
started and then rapidly it rises I
tweeted out looks like 460k might be the
limit this uh Twitter user lofty pixels
responded YouTube had 750 000 live
viewers for PlayStation showcase today
lol and posted this video from
PlayStation that had no problem with
this let me show you some of the red
actions we got we've got uh Donald Trump
Jr saying hashtag a disaster
yikes man yeah just given ammunition yup
that's a hashtag that's that's better
than desanctimonious yeah yeah way
better seriously way better that's Trump
Jr and then I think I got one more here
we go David wolf tweets Failure to
Launch crashed Rhonda Sanders 2024 and
uh sad faces from Ron and Elon looks
kind of like CGI
yeah yeah it looks a little AI right
well I mean there they're taking you
know they're not just taking a swing at
DeSantis they're taking a swing and musk
because the Twitter thing and the whole
rocket crashing you know making the the
link to SpaceX and stuff you know well
you brought up something interesting I
think it might have screwed up
everything if it was elon's account that
screwed everything up
and it switched over to David sacks
that's what I heard it would change the
whole vibe of the whole thing where it
wasn't like Elon asking DeSantis
questions it just like it became like
David
in the middle of it when it when it
first launched Elon was the host then
DeSantis then I think sax joined yeah
and they both had speaking Privileges
and one of the technical problems was
that while sax was speaking Elon unmuted
his phone and they're sitting next to
each other so you start hearing a
feedback loop and then
that's but for Elon to do that like why
did you unmute your account what are you
doing here well then it became David
sacks asking all the questions and
nobody was supposed to be and it wasn't
supposed to be no it was supposed to be
oh it was supposed to be I mean look
they they they might say oh it was
supposed to be Elon I don't I don't see
that why bring in sex at all he was
brought in before DeSantis yeah so isn't
he was he like a British journalist or
something no I mean he was he was like
the CEO of PayPal I think oh okay okay
so they're they're buds but they but I
mean the whole thing was sold is like
Elon asking the questions right like
even like we were going to the War Room
hosting a space yeah it's supposed to be
like the Elon interview type thing and
it didn't really happen
yeah it it didn't really just like
softball City and then after the crash
it just uh was was it was just not good
I mean it's just it's just like I mean a
lot of people left that took a lot of
women out of the sales I mentioned it
yesterday dude yesterday we wanted to
lead the show off with the uh the target
story because now it's getting crazier
Target is uh apparently the CEO she had
a statement saying yeah we're gonna get
rid of a bunch of stuff but we're gonna
Double Down basically saying we're gonna
try and hide this in the general public
but instead I'm like okay they basically
released this launch video so we have to
cover it but then what is there to cover
today if not just the same thing we
already know okay dude's running for
president then of course we got lucky in
that they failed so like a little mean
it's a little mean they did do the space
they did get the message out they did
get the announcement but I I do feel
like uh we got news out of the fact that
they kind of screwed up the launch and
they lost the majority of the audience
that was ready for this announcement but
it was like a snooze Fest yeah it was it
was this news I mean like you got in
there and you're like wow there's
nothing interesting here you got to come
with some well I mean think about like
no bangers I left relatively quickly the
new the only news that was there was was
it being done on a space everyone knew
that DeSantis was going to run DeSantis
didn't have anything there was no
Pizzazz to his actual speech or anything
so like really to come with something so
it's like it really was the interesting
thing was the fact that it was on
Twitter for the first time and then it
felt went back they ruined it could you
imagine if Elon abruptly launched a
space and then said Rhonda Santa isn't
making a big announcement they that
would have crashed all of Twitter way
faster than this would have so maybe
maybe they're trying to avoid that but
even in that regard DeSantis really
screwed this one up his Camp his
campaign because they could have gone on
Rumble and they could have been with Dan
bongino and that would have would have
held up just fine but he was like ooh
Elon Musk he's big we're gonna go for
this if he abruptly appeared in a live
stream with Dan bongino and Dan was like
I'm being joined by Iran I don't know if
Dan would want to do that because he's
more of a trump guy anyway but if Ron
did a show any any live stream and they
tweeted out Rhonda sentences here and
he's about to make an announcement you'd
get two million live viewers instead
they were like let's announce it
announce exactly what we're gonna
announce and then have a crash and it's
just like they end up with 190 000 or
some odd people listening when Ron
DeSantis makes his presidential
announcement and I was just like it's
good but for a presidential announcement
come on dude we had Stephen Crowder in
here on January we cracked that number
and he didn't even announce he was
running for president right yeah no he
was complaining he was just complaining
internet drama his internet drama
PlayStation like I mentioned did a
Showcase of video games at 757 000
people
that's brutal man yeah he should have
maybe saved this Elon moment for
something that was like really
newsworthy
you know like a big deal like something
like like the Stephen Crowder moment
right like where everybody's paying
attention and they're hanging on every
word they could have saved this for
something big at the right moment to
drop during the campaign I feel like hmm
yeah I don't know if this was the moment
I don't know this is like everybody knew
was coming it's like and then they
brought nothing into the table it's a
bad start yeah I mean do you think it
was just an effort to associate himself
with Elon because Elon is not
necessarily on the right or left but the
radical left really hates him and the
establishment is trying to fight him or
vice versa I don't know man I I don't I
I think what's interesting out of this
is Trump versus Elon I think that's a
more interesting Dynamic I think this is
going to be like I think Trump's going
to attack Elon more than he's gonna
attack anybody else on the course the
next time
oh they I mean they he attacks Elon all
the time I don't see how I mean that's
that's good in any way I don't I don't
think so either I just think it's
interesting it's gonna be interesting to
see him attack Elon coming out of this
thing as like I mean he's like you know
who he reminds me of a little bit I
don't know if you guys know Sheriff Joe
Arpaio yeah Sheriff Joe and Phoenix
where I'm from remembers every single
person that wronged him ever and puts
them on a list and attacks that no no no
no no no Trump doesn't do that Trump is
Trump attacks you only until you're nice
to him yeah as soon as you're nice to
him then he's but he's with you Trump is
is
like to Lion Ted yeah I mean we'll see
if Elon you can be pro-trump and still
be honest the guy is like the guy has no
principle he's the principle is winning
he's saying tiny Ron DeSantis yeah after
the primary is going to say Titan Rhonda
Sanders exactly Titan Rhonda said he's a
big man he's a big man you know the
supporters
this is one of the things Trump really
uh understands about politics very well
you know so many people in media will
Lampoon him for that kind of behavior
the fact that he'll just do a complete
180 on a person and I agree there's
something there that's laughable but the
media does that constantly they're
equally Shameless did you see uh Bill
Crystal I think called Trump and Alpha
today or yesterday it's it's so typical
and what they'll also do is you know
they will forward a narrative that
narrative will be completely disproven
and then they'll just jump to something
else or sometimes they'll jump to a
different narrative which is completely
contradictory to what they were stating
their goals are when representing the
other narrative so the media will take
advantage of the American people having
this short attention span and not
considering how current statements line
up against past statements and then
they'll laugh at Trump for doing the
exact same thing let's uh let's let's do
it we're gonna play the announcement for
you it's a it's a I guess it's seven
minutes long and uh before I start I
just want to mention we have a super
chat from uh where where are we at who
who said it
um beagle cakes says who has I don't
know who has more Charisma Mark
Zuckerberg or Rhonda Santos so I mean
it's a little biased start but let's
just play the play the video for you
Zuckerberg because you can Roll Jiu
Jitsu
um I understand that you may have an
announcement to make we've got I think a
record audience assembled here uh you
know the probably the biggest uh room
that's probably ever been assembled
online uh what would you like that was
such a sad statement yeah there's a
hundred and two people listening 102 000
and is it probably the biggest online
what do you say ever
stumbled here uh you know the probably
the biggest uh room that's probably ever
been assembled online what would you
like to tell them
well I am running for president of the
United States to lead our Great American
comeback look we know our country's
going in the wrong direction we see it
with our eyes and we feel it in our
bones our Southern borders collapse
drugs are pouring into the country our
cities are being hollowed out by spiking
crime the federal government's making it
harder for the average family to make
ends meet and to attain and maintain a
middle-class lifestyle and our president
well he lacks Vigor flounders in the
face of our nation's challenges and he
takes his cues from the woke mob I don't
think it has to be this way American
decline is not inevitable it is a choice
and we should choose a new Direction a
path that will lead to American
revitalization we must restore sanity to
our nation this means embracing fiscal
and economic sanity stop pricing
hard-working Americans out of a good
standard of living through inflationary
borrow print and spending policies and
please Embrace American Energy
Independence this also means replacing
the woke mind virus with reality facts
and enduring principles Merit must Trump
identity politics we must return
normalcy to our communities America is a
sovereign country our borders must be
respected we cannot have foreigners
pouring into our country illegally by
the millions we cannot allow drug
cartels to poison our population with
fentanyl public deserve safe communities
and Law and Order must be maintained in
American cities we can't have inmates
running the Asylum and we must reject
attacks on the men and women of law
enforcement we also must re-establish
Integrity in our institutions this
includes the military I'm proud to be a
Navy veteran and Iraq veteran and I
Revere our services but when revered
institutions like those in our military
are more concerned with matters not
Central to the mission whether it's
global warming or gender ideology and
pronoun sounds morale declines and
recruiting suffers and you need to
eliminate these distractions and we need
to get focused on the core Mission we
also cannot have true constitutional
government if the most significant
issues are decided by the whims of
unelected bureaucrats rather than the
people's elected representatives
re-establishing Integrity in our
institutions means we must reinvigorate
our constitutional system by returning
the government to its rightful owners We
the People no social that was just
without representation truth needs to be
our foundation oh my gosh it's only been
two minutes and 50 seconds virtue and in
Florida we proved we chose facts over
fear indication over indoctrination Law
and Order over rioting and disorder we
the words are great right the words are
great the delivery but it's like an AI
saying it exactly it's like it's not
even like an ad it's like a text message
recently ranked number one in education
we have a 50-year low crime rate and one
of the lowest tax in debt per capita in
America but we also understand governing
is not entertainment it's not about
building a brand or virtue signaling
us
and our results in Florida have been
Second To None we can and we must
deliver big results for America I pledge
to be an energetic executive that will
take
look me up
and we'll build an economy where working
Americans can achieve a good standard of
living Biden's opened the southern
border and allowed massive amounts of
drugs to pour into the country we'll
shut down the Border construct the
border wall and hold the drug cartel
we're building accountable bidens
Embrace medical authoritarianism such as
unconstitutional covid vax mandates we
will ensure that those violations of
Liberty can never happen again Biden's
allowed woke ideology to drive his
agenda we will never surrender to the
woke mob and we will leave woke ideology
into Dustbin of History come on Biden's
also politicized the military to plummet
we will eliminate ideological agendas
from our military Focus the military on
the core Mission and we will reverse the
poor recruiting Trends finally Biden's
weaponized the power of the
administrative State this is a cruel and
unusual publishing agenda we will
reconstitutionalize the executive branch
and will bring the administrative state
to heal now you can't do any of that if
you don't win there is no substitute for
victory we must then the culture of
losing that has infected the Republican
party in recent years the tired dogmas
of the past are inadequate for a vibrant
future we must look forward
backwards we need the courage to lead
and we must have the strength to win and
to voters who are participating in this
primary process my pledge to you is this
if you nominate me you can set your
clock to January 20th 2025 at High Noon
because on the west side of the U.S
Capitol I will be taking the oath of
office as the 47th president of the
United States no excuses I will get the
job done now these past few years have
given me a new appreciation for the
fragility of our freedoms I never
thought I would see things in America
that we saw during the covid-19 pandemic
but our founding fathers were keenly
aware of the fragility of Freedom when
they framed our constitution they came
to armed with having studied the history
of every Republic in the history of
mankind and they noticed that all of
those experiments only had one thing in
common and it was this every single one
of them had failed and so they knew it
fell to our country the United States of
America to determine whether people
could really govern themselves could we
have a society based on the idea that
our rights are god-given not government
granted and that what Society functions
based on the rule of law not the rule of
individual men and when Dr Benjamin
Franklin walked out of that convention
he was asked did you deliver a republic
or a monarchy he said a republic if you
can keep it they knew Freedom didn't run
on emphasis on you the only thing he
ever has a responsibility to safeguard
freedom and it's our responsibility to
do so at this important juncture in our
nation's history we have a lot of work
to do to ensure the country gets back on
track I ask everybody listening to
please join me on this Mission please
invest in our campaign by going to Ron
desantis.com and making a donation thank
you God bless and I look forward to the
discussion
look I really I want to turn it off but
it's like a presidential announcement so
I thought like for the sake of hearing
it people need to be able to hear it but
dude yeah I I couldn't believe it when
he got to the part about a republic if
you can keep it I'm like listen man I
like Rhonda Sanders as a politician he
has great policies he's doing a great
job
but holy crap did they not give this guy
one minute of meeting training did they
not have any kind of of campaign coach
be like go watch Captain America one
time
and just watch watch any Hollywood movie
where the protagonist gives a speech
about saving the world just just that in
fact watch SNL as they mock that look
man
the Santa's people are probably gonna
get mad because they like him but I'm
not pulling punches I like Elon I like
DeSantis but that had negative Charisma
negative I agree I look I I like
DeSantis a lot I think everything he was
saying there was spot on every single
word but I'll be honest I was I was
literally bored to tears I mean it's
remarkable to me that someone who said
so many things that were so true that
would have gotten a standing ovation
from any group of conservatives who are
outside of the establishment where they
just delivered with a little bit more
energy could be so boring when addressed
in such a plain monotone way I think
that you're right he needs media
training again I'm not trying to be
harsh on the guy there's all there's a
lot about DeSantis which is really
really great he has to fix this I has to
fix guys I really don't want to play
this video for you
because it's just I don't think Rhonda
said his has the has the personality for
for being president
but for the sake of just letting you
guys watch it for yourselves this is
Rhonda Santos's tweeted Out official
announcement video
[Applause]
confess our cities
federal government makes
a maker for families to make ends meet
and the president flounders but decline
is a choice success is attainable and
freedom is worth fighting for writing
the ship requires restoring sanity to
our society normalcy to our communities
and integrity to our institutions
truth must be our foundation and Common
Sense can no longer be an uncommon
virtue in Florida we prove that it can
be done the music we chose facts over
fear education over indoctrination Law
and Order over rioting and disorder we
held the line when Freedom hung in the
bounds we showed that we can and must
Revitalize America we need the courage
to lead and the strength to win I'm Ron
DeSantis and I'm running for president
to lead our Great American comeback
I'm gonna I'm gonna say something
shockingly offensive to all the Genesis
fans oh boy
Joe Biden's got better presence and
presentation than Rhonda Santos does now
now hold on there a minute before you
freak out Joe Biden does have a mental
Affliction yeah which gives Joe Biden
the making it's not entertaining yeah
when Biden says
pressure okay like we get it that's
incomprehensible mumbled garbage but at
the very least let me let me let me play
a little bit for you sanity to our
society normalcy to our communities and
integrity to our institutions
truth must be our foundation now imagine
how Joe Biden would deliver that yeah we
got to bring some some Integrity some
truth
I think I mentioned this before the show
but I think DeSantis needs to be able to
announce that he's running for president
with at least the same amount of energy
that Joe Biden announced he had hairy
legs with seriously I mean we we need
some actual Spirit Behind these
statements again I got Ariel eggs I got
Ariel legs like he meant it I was like I
believe you I believe you Joe
super weird you're very creepy but I do
believe your legs are hairy okay there's
some level of enthusiasm you need and
part of the reason that this is so
difficult for people is because DeSantis
and Trump even though they're Rivals
they've been associated with each other
in many ways right The Establishment has
smeared DeSantis in somewhat similar
ways to the ways they smeared Trump uh
before they started running against each
other their bases were similar but the
thing you got to remember is Trump was
an outsider DeSantis is a politician
even though he's not in line with the
establishment on many of the things that
they want him to be in line with them on
uh he's still a politician and he does
kind he I mean he has that boring
political way of speaking and I I would
go as far as to say it's actually worse
for him than it is a lot of other uh
politicians so part of it is we have
this expectation sent by Trump that we
should have a leader who's really going
to be charismatic and energetic and also
the fact that is like even more boring
than most other politicians are when he
speaks even though I like what the guy
does even though he's he's very much
impressed me I mean one of one of the
things he said earlier on quite a long
time ago is that he didn't want to be in
a political Foxhole with anyone who
isn't pro-life I think that's fantastic
I mean I think that is fantastic there's
a lot he does that's phenomenal but man
you gotta you gotta tune the energy up
man we'll turn the energy up so I have
his quote
it's he said but we know our country is
going in the wrong direction we see it
with our own eyes and we feel it in our
bones I am running for president of the
United States to lead our Great American
comeback if you were to imagine Joe
Biden saying that he'd say something
like but we know our country's going in
the wrong direction we see their own
eyes come on man we filling our bones I
read that he'd probably say we fill in
our Biggums yeah I don't know what that
word is but but there's like I'm not
trying to say that Joe Biden conveys
ideas properly no but the emotions in
those ideas he has a lot of big feelings
yeah good old job I mean running big
events I mean we run some of the biggest
events at turning point and Shout out we
have we just announced that Trump's
gonna be speaking in our big action
conference uh on July 15th and 16th of
West Palm Beach but uh right before this
but doing this I think what was the
weird part about this whole announcement
is you have to warm up the speaker they
should have treated this whole thing
like it was he was going on stage I mean
they had a video of him on a big stage
it's him in front of a flag without
cheering all of the back none of it felt
like there was a big crowd there so
they're put they're showing this video
of him like Solo in front of a flag and
they're on Twitter spaces and he came in
cold after after technical difficulty
why did they have a whole program where
it was like warm-up speakers get the
crowd hyped like add to the like the way
like they should have built the thing up
to be hundreds of thousands of followers
anything that that exact video would
have been fine if they didn't use
pensive staccato violins yes they'd had
better music that actually had some
impact I'm telling you I am telling you
I think the visual of him just like
alone though I guarantee that music was
pensive that's that made people feel
anxiety it didn't feel epic seriously
that kind of that kind of biking
absolutely no no look look I think the
music is fine but not with this
presentation I think the presentation
could work if it had better music you
get this really intense boom and he's
going and we've got to have truth in our
nation it's like they do not go together
let me point out this one piece here
you're not able to see him on this
Twitter space right which I think is so
stupid I mean this is is it yeah what is
this this isn't like the early 20th
century you can't see the guy I know
this is basically like radio he's
basically an FDR you know he could he he
couldn't walk maybe he couldn't walk
maybe he maybe he didn't have
functioning legs we wouldn't know with
him he's using this medium that nobody
can see him with a video they should
have built this whole thing where it was
like his whole production they've had
months and months and months and months
that where it's like he's in a room with
a lot of people why can't you why can't
you do this whole thing in a room with a
lot of people yeah yeah no I mean it's a
good point I think you were absolutely
spot on when he said there should have
been an audience there energy stage
there should have been people but
warm-up act yeah I'm actually I'm
actually but this this is sort of what
I'm saying right it's it's remarkable to
me when something with so much money and
power behind it is done so poorly I mean
these are really basic things you don't
have to be an expert political analyst
to know that those things would have
helped him and not just that they would
have helped him but that they're kind of
bare necessities
I just I would have thought they would
have at least had some kind of General
Media training and and what gets me is
that was their finished product that was
them saying we we got it did we get it
we got it we're good we're good we're on
there yeah like when we watch these
Biden videos and they're jump cutting
like crazy because you know the dude is
completely incapable of speaking at this
point
you watch that and I'm just thinking to
myself it's the best thing they wrapped
they went to the ad and said guys this
is it they could have called him back in
and said Hey Ron we really need to have
a coach here who's going to tell you how
to say these lines so like for instance
when I'm doing uh Sheamus will ask me to
read some lines for Freedom Tunes he's
got to be here to tell me how to do the
lines because it might say something
like oh boy I'm gonna go buy an ice
cream cone and then I say oh boy I'm
gonna buy an ice cream cone and then
James will be like no say oh boy I'm
gonna go buy an ice cream cone like you
gotta say it's yeah short here like you
need direction when you didn't have it
when we're like when I'm when I'm
recording like we're doing a record or
whatever there's three things that the
producer is going to tell me he's gonna
tell me either my timing's bad he's
going to tell me my notes are bad or
he's going to tell me I don't believe it
you gotta believe it you have to be
performing if you're up there and you're
talking to a crowd you need the crowd to
believe what you're saying they need to
believe that you believe it that's the
first thing and this you have to believe
it you have to tell them that that that
that you believe it and this is why
Trump basically always crushes right
because he always yes always sells that
he believes it this is why he can get
away with going on television and saying
something completely different than he
said a few days ago about a particular
person
he believes it exactly exactly he's
really in it people likely he shows up
and just starts talking yep yeah there's
a weird element to that that people like
they've liked since day one and that's
what lit a fire under people to be like
oh you know what I'm don't like Ted Cruz
anymore I like Donald Trump in 16.
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time